okay hello everyone
welcome to the third live stream of the
day
um
this is a wolfram language design review
part of our language completeness and
consistency series and we have a variety
of topics to go
over here
converting um
um
converting out of core audio to encore
okay so the basic point here is
we've got
um right so we
don't have anything like this right what
we have right now is a store now button
that you know when you have an
expression that's too large to fit in
the notebook
you know you're given the option to
store
that expression which is not saved in
the notebook which is
you know you can embed it directly in in
the notebook or you can in fact save it
in a local object which is an external
uh
okay so kernel file
and it also allows me to store in cloud
right
well this is all magnificent yeah
right
so now you want a similar sort of button
for
out of core audios but the first point
i'm making that is a completely
different operation because you're
taking one expression
and you're changing it to a completely
different expression right you're
basically
importing the file
um
and
right the audio gui is very really quite
different from summary boxes
so there are ux design type questions
here
okay so hold on let me understand this
if i
do this
to me
this feels like a thing i mean i don't
know that this isn't in court sitting
here
and it doesn't happen to me but i don't
know that
yes you do it because you see there's a
file name
oh yeah yeah yeah but that's just that's
technical detail i mean i that's just i
i see a dot dot blah blah the main point
here is
i i don't understand the difference i
really don't i mean i know
implementationally it's different but i
don't understand from a user point of
view why it's different
because you won't lose that data if you
quit the kernel whereas you will you
lose the data that's an out of 40.
so what i mean okay yes that's different
i agree i agree that's the difference
right one is about
you know preserving results
that that you know you get
hold on if i say store local object what
does this then look like after i press
store and local object i'll try it
okay
that
is deeply analogous to this
right because again i won't lose the
data if i exit the program
right
correct
so it's really the same situation as
with the audio file
that has um i'm confused about this
personality uh case that i am not super
familiar with does the input form of
that change
is this sparse array of local object i
don't know
it's the input form changes if you look
at the
held form right you need to hold it
right because
so yeah absolutely the
okay there it is it's just like an audio
object
right
but right you had nothing there and you
slurped something in
i don't understand that comment
right
if if you
right if you copy out of 40 and put it
in an input cell and try to evaluate it
nothing will happen
if i take out a 40 yeah
copy that paste it into an input cell
with its location i'm sorry sorry not
that one because yeah exactly this one
i'm watch this
right
of course because it evaluated
to right you imported it it turned into
a spies array and that sparse or a
typeset
right which is really quite different
from the audio file
right there's a non-trivial evaluation
there
i don't understand why you're saying
this i don't understand am i being
really stupid here to me
this okay good the okay to me
this case of the sparse array stored on
a local object its default happens to be
different
but that case that non-default case for
sparse array seems identical to this
case here what am i missing
well there's no button there to store it
right you're wanting to add a button now
there is no button to store i know i
know that's why we're talking about this
because i want to add no no no no no no
no the local the sparse array has no
button
you want to add a button to audio but if
they're completely analogous there
should be no button because the local
object one has no button on it
what local object one has no button this
one here because it's already stored
exactly
just like the data in car okay i get i
finally understand what you're saying i
consider this as something of a detail
but i understand what you're saying
okay so what i'm proposing is that in
this case
you know
you are storing it in a second place and
you're going to use that other pointage
just like you can do that with
persistent value you can point to a
different persistence location if you
want to
so here
you know i'm saying
you know persistence
it differently from the way it was
persisted before
okay well that's a different button
which needs to be designed and we need
to think about the ux i'm not saying
that this button shouldn't exist
my point is that it's not the same as
this existing button
even if we ignore the fact that the
audio okay i get your point i finally
understood your point although i think
it's a little bit of a narrowly defined
point but yes i agree i agree with my
points there's also the point that like
right the audio gui has it three sizes
so where and when do we show this and
how and how do we phrase it okay okay
okay but you understand why it has
extremely high value to do this
maybe you don't understand i i no i
don't because if i wanted to do that i
would just put an import and evaluate in
place
no that won't work why won't that won't
work it will absolutely will work dude
okay but i don't think it's the right
way to do it because i think people are
going to get confused so people have
already confused also
that audio object to transform it into
an incur
we have this very weird usage of normal
of it that
stirs all the data into the input form
of the
of the audio so it is obscure i think a
button would help
okay well i'm not saying there shouldn't
be a button i'm just saying
you're right i was wrong
okay although i claim i was only wrong
in detail okay now what is my god what
is that
right so now it's an encore object it
imported it right i mean what that what
if i
right
if i had done audio of import of that
file rather than audio of that file with
that or in fact if i just an import of
that file name right would i've gotten
the same object as that normal there
uh
so this is something that was decided
ages ago that i have never been
particularly happy there's a heuristic
on the length of the signal
where
import does two different things
according to the length of the signal so
the answer is if the
length is below the threshold yes it
will be an incur one if it is over it
will be an out of curl one
oh so what does normal do in that case
or no no
no no no so so so import basically does
nothing it just returns audio file of
law if if the length is uh bigger than a
threshold right so we need a way to
affirmatively say
and and so does normal
respect this threshold or will normal no
normal will always try to bring stuff
which means you can crash the front end
if it's a very large audio file
absolutely absolutely
so maybe normal should respect uh
dollar inline
no it's a system option um right we have
a system option for
you know above which the it we don't
present this store in
inline in the notebook button that's not
accessible
however this kind of
unclear behavior is
yes i agree yeah
yeah no but that is a valid point no
objection
and i was asking
offline to tool about how big
numeric arrays are stored in general big
chunks of data are stored in the cells
at the moment it's using compressed data
a more efficient way would be to
serialize the data with a flak glossless
compression similar to discussions that
we've had with john about images to
minimize a bit the
uh
weight on the front end of each of these
in colorado objects
right but that that means updating the
notebook format right
right yes you so
so i mean this is something of course
that
uh
that i'm considering is how we can
update the notebook format in a way
that's not going to cause
uh significant compatibility problems
and i have some thoughts about that
um
absolutely i missed we're not gonna
we're not gonna solve this problem over
the next month just to be clear
okay can we solve the one problem that
we can solve which is
a button to do a better defined version
of what this was doing here
so i think right so i think i mean lou
seems to think and i i don't know if
carlo agrees that the implementation
of the button would as in
the the kernel level or
functionality is pretty clear right we
just need to yeah
in a sensible way so the input film can
be replaced
right um i think the more the more
complicated questions uh are you know
what does the bun button look like when
do we show it
uh right and do we show it in all three
states presumably we don't show it in
the tiny state okay i'm going to make a
suggestion okay i don't think note
seeing the file name is in the slightest
bit useful
i think that what should be done here is
it should just say paren
data not in notebook or something you
know x number of megabytes per and data
data not in that notebook paren x number
of megabytes
and then it should have a mouse over
that says or or something like this
i don't know in a small state because
that real estate that you're using there
to to give a file name that nobody cares
about
just doesn't seem worthwhile i'm not
sure it's true that nobody cares about
it now i think it would be useful if it
was really just the file name right the
problem there is that it's giving
the whole path right if that's just said
car.mp3
i might actually care about that as
opposed to you know honking okay let me
let me ask you another question is there
a fast like for cryptography we have the
feature that you can tell if two things
are the same
by you know if if you say
all right
if you go into the big state right you
shouldn't you see uh
you see the full file name
but
what's interesting here is if i say
table of generate symmetric key
it's not as clear as it might be but
those it's clear it's somewhat clear
those are different
even though i don't know what they
actually are
now we could imagine doing a similar
thing with these files because really
the main thing you need to know
is just that they're different or
whatever so the tooltip
does help with that it shows you a
snippet of the waveform that is a very
good point
right and if you go into the expanded
state do you see the waveform or not no
there is the if when stuff is playing
that waveform will play so there's no
indication of the content of the whole
object it's just what it's playing right
now i mean if we just had a tiny icon
icon of the waveform it seems like it
would be really worthwhile
that would be kind of expensive to
compute though
then don't do it that way
i i for one would i think the file name
is useful if you're importing
you know a dozen
mp3s you want to know which one came
from which
file at a glance you don't want to have
to look at tool tips
also another point that i would like to
make is that
i'm not sure we should be that
aggressive to the user saying they don't
know your notebook and kind of
uh menacing disaster
for that just because i would because
there will be there will be a disaster
no no and so there are other ways to fix
that right not immediately what
okay now give me a stack just give me a
second to finish my thought here so
first of all uh importing data into
notebook without making changes to the
notebook format
can result in gigantic stuff being
stored in a notebook for example a three
minute audio file
three three megabytes as an mp3 will be
a hundred and something in the front end
each time it is displayed which is not
great right
no that's not good
yeah um
one of the solutions that will be
involved in having a version of
compressed data that just is the string
version of the mp3
yeah so this is one of the things that
we're looking at mp3 is not great
obviously
because it's compressed but there are
other formats that are lossless
so yes that is one of the
one of the uh
potential options that i don't know that
much about but john probably will have a
more uh sensible answer than mine so the
other point is that data in notebook
right now is not useful because of the
blow-up factor and it it depends on the
use right if it's a small audio and you
want to share your notebook with someone
else then yeah
that is well the alternative is to store
it in the cloud
yes
audio of cloud object is a valid audio
object so absolutely that the button
should allow you to do that
for sure
um
one thing that that john mentioned in
one of the meetings uh
was the whole concept of assets that
could rely on the temporary file system
that would be
another easy way to bundle stuff with
the notebook
um
sure but i'm not sure
that's a much more complicated story
well it's i'm i'm i'm hoping to find
a subset of that story that is
uh
simple enough that that we can deliver
uh something useful for thirteen two it
will definitely be a subset let me be
extremely clear about that but uh
uh but i don't think that's off the
table
so
and all of all of the things i was
saying that is not to say that a story
notebook button or stirring cloud button
would not be useful i am just saying
that it shouldn't be as aggressive as
the thing that is right okay
then why don't we do this
maybe we should put paran
file after this
yeah
i was actually going to suggest the
opposite which is maybe
not
not necessarily mutually exclusive which
for the inline ones rather than just
having the little tiny waveform there
that we say in notebook or something
like that
well that's no that's that's fine but
that's not the um
that one i agree with you we should do
that
but this one here
uh
you know we need to deal with this one
because this is the one that is coming
up by default most of the time and
that's the one from which you need to be
storing cloud
am i making sense
yeah i think both during cloud and
storage notebook are useful so fine
i'm talking about the ux i'm talking
about a question for the ux
um after you've stored it in cloud might
you then want to store it in the
notebook
yes in other words this button persists
in a way that it doesn't in the case of
sparse array
well
you could say the same thing about
sparse array couldn't you
i mean you can't have it
in the case of the cloud
if it says data stored in local object
data stored in cloud you you i mean
actually
that this thing here might not be bad to
include that and have it be able to be
trans transferred
do you know what i'm saying
sure
i mean the difference in the case of
sparse array is that you can always get
the data once you have it stored in any
form
you can always get at the data and then
in the new output you have a new choice
but yes we could provide that same
choice
i mean the same thing's true here
is that true by the way if you start the
local the specified data in your local
object and then open it the computer on
something that doesn't have that local
object no you're screwed in that case
same thing as for the file system
that's what the word local means
okay so i i i i don't know enough about
the object system does uh
uh
so i i guess the the uuid it it's it's
this isn't a content addressable thing
at all the uuid is
uh
randomly assigned which means there's
going to be no matching between a local
object and what you might consider a
corresponding cloud object
it would be very interesting idea to use
a hash
perhaps we should do that
right i mean you can at least
you write you can name
both cloud objects and local objects i
know but john is suggesting something
which i think is rather interesting
which is the possibility of a
unique object or something well
in general content addressability you
know defining an address based on the
contents
um so as long as the contents don't
change the address is universal
i kind of like this idea of having a new
kind of object
that is the shared kind of you know and
maybe maybe it should be part of the
persistent object discussion
something called um
you know content addressed object or
something or a better name
that just has a uuid and you might
happen to have it or not
i i and for some reason that's not how
we've done the persistent object
mechanism i don't know why well i mean i
mean there's there's a downside to it i
mean you know content addressable
doesn't help you find the thing if you
modified it
uh
so
you know if it's likely to be modified
not so helpful uh you need another
you know another indexing system for
that but i i think we need to have a
discussion that involves roman
uh who did the you know persistent
object system
about this idea okay so fork that off
please that's for avery i guess
um
got it
now okay so for this
let's just agree on what roughly the gui
has to look like
i think
i really want to say that
i i think what's currently one row needs
to become two rows right
it
you have the little icon and then it
should say you know an external file or
local object or cloud object or in
notebook and then on the second line you
see the file name
possibly just the last path component
right you do file name take of -1
so all you see is car.mp3 and then maybe
it's at a readable font size so you
actually know
what file you're looking at okay can i
make a suggestion this look see where
it's stored in it says store and local
object why not say here
file open bracket dot dot dot blah blah
close bracket
and then simply have in the iconic form
simply have one of those arrow things
with the mouse over
what i'm saying
i well i still object to getting rid of
the file name entirely no i'm not
suggesting it i'm saying
i i i i i i i i
you didn't mean a literal dot that you
meant file of well
stephen followed the dot dot dot by blah
blah blah i think he meant you know your
file name take of negative one for blah
blah blah okay
that's what i meant is that i
misunderstood sorry
right so that what that's what i've
suggested
and perhaps lose that icon on the left
so the the usefulness of the icon is it
tells you
what is the source of this if there's a
notebook if it is file look at this look
at what i'm suggesting look at what i'm
suggesting i'm suggesting just like we
do it up here
that we put this in that space file of
blah blah blah yeah and i understand i
was just my point was only that the eye
couldn't seem a bit more compact and
there's a bit more obscure as well
right so if we do i interpreted that
waveform in
out of 45 as the literal waveform of the
notebook object but now now that we've
discussed this more i'm presuming that
that's just a generic representation of
this is correct
right so yes definitely obscure if
yeah so okay so then then in this case
here i think we would say
uh
you know because we don't have an
analogous thing we'd say in notebook
stored in a notebook we can probably fit
that whole thing
that's what i would suggest and then
after each one of these the arrow thing
with a with the hover effect that allows
you to to change where it's stored i'm
making sense
yeah it makes sense and i right i don't
think we'll need any new assets for this
i mean maybe there's some implementation
detail but
um
carlo is this something you think you
can easily do
yeah i mean the implementation of
switching etc etc that will be very easy
um anytime we touch up this gui it ends
up being a kind of a bigger project but
this
is probably smaller than the ones that
we've done in the past fine so i mean
this particular in this case when it's
plush like this we can have both the
icon and
the names like this
so there is another case that we haven't
looked at at all the tiny one
right and i think the tiny one there's
just no hope right yeah
i don't think there's much that can be
done there no there's nothing you can do
there yeah except maybe on hover why
isn't there anything on hover here
there is no
play button right
there there is a it just says the word
play right but we could we could thicken
that up and say something like play and
then underneath we could say something
like a file name or something but we
could have a hover on the down arrow at
least
it's a minor luxury in my opinion yeah
yeah maybe we saved that for round two
okay so i mean i could imagine hold on i
could imagine that the iconography of
the play button could change slightly
i feel like that would be extremely
excuse as well as the icons that we have
currently
what's that
i think that would be very obscure
yeah well it wouldn't be obscured with
the cognoscenti who might be the ones
who will be most concerned about that
when they have a list
and then um i mean you can make the same
argument for the current icons
yeah and i agree for the cognizant it
works fine
all right let's go on we are we good on
this topic
i think so
yeah great
thank you and let's move on stylesheet
beep
right so you sent an email with this uh
uh basically just screenshot and maybe
a subject line
okay this is something so wait let me
right so
if right i think we all agree that
people shouldn't write backlits that
have bad stylesheets in them
given that
when a stylesheet can't be found
right
i don't know what else it can do
but what is the issue you see here
well i think the main issue i saw was
that i was completely confused where the
stylesheet was
and for example knowing not knowing the
search path that it followed made me
just i you know i just started searching
on my computer for it's just total mess
but i think my major issue was just that
the shared style sheet
the shared style sheet wasn't hadn't
been shared was the main issue it was
shared between notebooks but it was not
shared
across computer and other things
so you're subjecting to the word shared
right so no i'm not really objecting i i
don't think i have an objection i had a
broader objection to the fact that
uh
you know that i couldn't find the style
sheet
that i had been led into a situation
where the stylesheet was somewhere
random in my file system i had no idea
where i had no idea where it was looking
and i thought the style street should be
in the cloud
but i think we've got a separate
discussion going about how to fix that
right okay
so i don't think that's anything
so john do you think there's anything
here uh
yeah i mean
so kind of
what we were discussing with a little
bit of hand waving here because there's
some you know there's there's there's a
bit where you know a miracle happens but
uh
uh
the
you know the kind of notion that i'm
thinking about right now is first of all
instead of getting a
modal dialogue uh you would get
you know an attached cell sort of
interface
that would give you the option
if you so chose to
go more aggressively looking for the
style sheet
um
and and what we mean by more
aggressively looking for the style sheet
would be
uh looking in the cloud looking in
resource repositories that sort of thing
this is a thing which will take time
so
uh
so the i don't know a button saying
browse for stylesheet
under here instead of the okay
the
big
i i i really don't think
it's i i think it's very rare that that
will solve the problem it's very rare
that you will successfully find the
style sheet you were looking for on your
uh i mean in this case
the for example the likely reason that
you couldn't find it was because uh the
style sheet was provided by docutools
you didn't have the docutools packlet
installed
um
and
let me tell you
it's you complain about not seeing the
stylesheet path but if you saw the
stylesheet path
it would just be you know a path salad
that you would then come back and
complain about the past salad and the
past salad is in part because the paclet
manager is doing all kinds of work to
extend paths as needed for new backlits
yeah
um
so
you know that's not where the magic
that you're seeking is going to happen
you know somehow reaching out to find it
on your system
yes there are exceptions but i think
those exceptions are rare um
so
you know it's more likely that it's a
missing packlet or maybe it's a style
sheet that we can encourage people to
publish in the stylesheet repository
when that's a thing
or you know something along those lines
um
and so that's where the currently that's
where the hand waviness a miracle
happens here sort of thing is but
uh but when we get to the point where we
have an implementation for that which
might be slow
uh but we can have an interface which is
uh uh you know basically provides what
is very clearly going to be an
asynchronous sort of operation
and allowing you to kind of still
proceed to do things in you know what
may be an ugly view right now but with
the understanding that the front end is
trying to go out and search for a thing
and if it succeeds then boom everything
will become beautiful and if it fails
you'll get a notification of i i tried
really hard but i couldn't find it in
the end
all right listen i am much more
interested in having style sheets be
able to routinely be put in the cloud
because then we just won't have this
issue
a stylesheet repository and start sheet
deployment in the cloud we're just not
going to have the system
so therefore that's my path as far as
i'm concerned and yeah
go ahead
and and and that's exactly what i'm
saying is that uh
you know
the
uh
i mean you know the problem you're gonna
have is that oh you published a notebook
that
you know points to a style sheet that
you know it doesn't have a cloud object
resource object or whatever as a style
sheet it's just a local thing well you
can go out into the world and fix it
after the fact that's what i'm saying
okay we find that style sheet we publish
in the style sheet repository and we fix
it for notebooks that are already out
there
okay
um
okay i i'm sorry i i want to check i'm
surprised we're not seeing anything here
from uh from brett
on
the many
things that i've sent in which were
various issues with
bar charts and this and that well if you
sent them to him and not to tlcc i i
sent them i i okay maybe i sent them to
ild
we do have a issue we're going to talk
about next week with brett about
outliers um but oh yeah yeah design
didn't have a time to look at it so we
wanted to make sure they had time
okay
there's some other things brett about
bar chart that i've sent
your way
yep yeah we'll get those all together
okay all right whether to allow general
patterns
right so this is this is something that
was
recently reported by an external user
but i think you know sort of looking
into the history it's actually been
reported sort of multiple times over the
years
right so right now if you do symbol
colon
something
the result right that's a short form for
pattern
if you do
blank
then it's optional
and sort of anything else
colon is a syntax error
um
and there are times when you actually
might want optional with sort of
non-trivial patterns you don't know i
agree
not trivial right-hand sides of the
optional
right this who you're talking about is
x-blank
colon
f of
something like this oh i'm i'm
absolutely not talking about that i'm
talking about a case like
a or
b
colon
a
like this
yes
and
[Music]
how does that parse like that
how did that
okay that's a syntax error
right
okay
well look this is related to the
composite patterns problem
which we tried to solve in the 1990s
i mean this really isn't i mean this is
a parsing question
right
to define the question more more
precisely
right so if you
right well like i said if you write so
so maybe
so right do x colon
blank slash
full form
okay
and then do x
blank colon d
full form
uh
right so that's optional
pattern and of course then there's x
colon blank colon d which is basically
another
thing
now if you want a complicated if if you
basically want that in a 50 only you
want to use a pattern that isn't simply
blank or blank blank you know some
short form of blank
is the only thing that's allowed right
now
you can't do that you either have to
write
optional
you know blah blah blah
it's this case here right it's this case
here exactly
okay i i think that syntax is dangerous
i don't think it's that important and i
think if you really want to use optional
okay
and i think there's too many weird cases
of that left hand side
being i mean i haven't thought about
thought through any of them
semi and you know
i don't know this doesn't
offend me that this doesn't work
and everybody who's trying to do this
you know can figure out that it should
be optional i think
anybody else have an opinion about this
i worry this is going to blow away some
syntax that we really want to use
anybody else have an opinion
you want to
add another meaning to colon
in the future so what you're saying
i don't know i'm worried about listen
i'm worried about about diagrams that
have a colon in them
i mean i didn't really care about this
before but if you're suggesting we might
add other meanings to colon maybe i want
to lock this down now so we can prevent
that
john i'm not suggesting adding a
different meaning to colon i'm
suggesting a diagram okay
and i have not thought through all the
diagrams that you might have here do you
see what i'm saying diagrams like this
because there are limited set of
diagrams that we have
from the standard pattern constructs
that we're currently using
right yeah that's what i'm concerned
about i'm concerned that i have not
thought this through i mean we could
look at all possible diagrams that you
get by having something but if we have a
general expression on the left-hand side
we have no control over that
and if it isn't a general expression
what's not general about it you know you
have slash semi and then some whole
elaborate thing
maybe if the precedence works
as long as you're not trying to get
close parenthesis colon
working as a diagram
i think you're okay because worst case
you can always wrap the thing in
parentheses
okay i just don't think this is worth
doing i think it has some danger and i
don't think it's worth doing
i mean
okay i mean they're they're like i said
there are there we we've had
complaints about this over the years but
i i don't think i don't think it's a big
deal and
we can always right we can i suppose we
can always change our minds if we say if
we document it as not working now but
change our minds in the future we can
always well then we have a new feature
look this now works
right
i think we should document this not
working
okay right so this is basically
you know the subject line um
it doesn't i think it's freaking crazy
okay
i think that if clear all of all
maybe
even that seems totally weird to me
this is like an rm-r star
that happens by default
yep
yeah it seems dangerous to me too
i mean if if you had to write something
more explicitly in there like all for
example
maybe it's worthwhile
um
can take symbols right so we couldn't we
couldn't do that because then i mean i
suppose you wouldn't i don't understand
why clear all of star
doesn't work i mean that does work
doesn't it yeah that does work
so what happens about that but that but
that will delete everything on dollar
context path right
um
not just dollar context
right
well maybe we need another um
i don't know we need something like this
and will backtick star work
oh that's an interesting question i
don't know
um somebody there with me can try it
or
well i think the real question is does
names of tactics star give you things
only in global or does it give you other
things
okay so this already works okay so we uh
yeah so i say we just disagree with
suggestion and we can let the user know
and document this document this for
goodness sake yep and even in basic
usage perhaps
basically examples and certainly in the
in the details
that's useful yep
right so
we decided not to use system exception
for iteration limit and recursion limit
but of course we still have system
exception for you know various
low-level
errors like malloc
i'm very pleased by the way with the the
thing that um
with what we came up with for the um
the dollar occurs in a minutes on i like
it very much
oh of course i can't find it because it
isn't documented exactly um
funny okay so explain to me what exactly
it does
so it's basically well it doesn't do
anything
but it causes a return
it no it doesn't cause a return when a
function runs
into certain low-level failures like
malloc fails
then if it's properly if it's properly
written
it will
it will throw an exception
in order to unwind a stack and hopefully
get back to a better state
and what it will throw will have had
system exception so that you can
specifically try to
right it's basically a
special head
um
so that you know if you want to catch
these particular kinds of exceptions you
can do a catch of blank
system exception
and catch specifically those as opposed
to any other
but if they're not caught they will be
thrown to the top level is that correct
right
so what else does that abort does that
but what else does that
abort is only catchable with
checkerboard
uh correct
uh
yes
um
there's um
well i mean it's
well well i mean no no but but this
isn't a board this isn't like a board
this is like dollar aborted
this is the value this
this has no down code or own code
this is this is just i understand so
what happens is i try and do malloc of a
quintillion
and it returns null but what comes back
here
is a thing where
well
it's literally an exception as if at
that point in the code you did throw of
blah
only the specific thing you're throwing
has had system exception to indicate
that it was this low-level error as
opposed to what else is auto throwing
um
well a board uh
looks different
i mean right if you
okay but does that work the same way i
mean can those be caught with catch
no
right the the catch can only catch
things that are caught by
which are thrown by throw
okay but so we've got a new form of
aborting which is system exception
aborting
which is
well i i disagree that it's
new well actually and relative to a
board i mean i guess yes yes
yes and it's
and it's because
a board is safe for the case where the
user stops the computation whereas this
is
oh my god i'm about to crash let me try
to not crash yes but but i understand
there's an important difference which is
abort
returns to the top level and is
uncatchable except with checkerboard
correct whereas this
strangely
is catchable
by catch
not by confirming close
not by checkerboard but by catch
um
i suppose although confirm and close are
ultimately just using their own catch as
well they're just using specific they're
just i know they're just using
auto-generated tags that the user
doesn't see i know i know i know that
you know but it's the exact mechanism
yeah i i know i know but the fact is
here
that
look
i don't understand why the malloc
failure doesn't just return system
exception without doing a throw
why does it do a throw i mean by the
time it's protected itself enough to
return a system exception why doesn't
just leave it at that and be happy
uh because uh things may not know that
right
things may not know that the reason
it
well that's the same as you have with
the recursion limit
and danny isn't here to defend recursion
limits but basically the mechanism
but but it's it's
right i mean
this is for cases where in the past the
colonel would just say no more memory
let me quit now i understand i got it i
know it's the same thing as for the
recursion limit where it says no more
stack space i
quit uh
except it's not really saying that it's
it's sort of guessing that
right because i know
because the recursion limit is
user-settable i i know i know i know but
the fact is that that right now the new
mechanism for recursion limit is what
to return a failure object right there
and not propagate the error correct
uh
well no it's basically throwing up to a
certain
level in the evaluator which then
catches it and replaces that with
a
you know with uh so with another
evaluation failure or whatever
evaluation terminated right valuation
terminated
um
and okay so the argument so in this case
right so there are there are in fact
functions that catch this system
exception and we'll you know might try a
different algorithm or something i i get
it i get it so the argument that i'm
making is system exception should work
exactly like terminated evaluation
possibly it should even be a terminated
evaluation with cause system exception
from the way you're describing system
exception i believe it is the same as
terminated evaluation and the decision
to kind of you know run away and and
throw to top level
um
is
uh
you know
seems i don't understand it relative to
the recursion limit case
but we don't do that i don't see any
reason more to do that in this case than
in that case
um
yeah
well i suppose i can discuss that with
rob
i thought he was going to be here i
don't know where where the breakdown
happened because he's the real expert on
on these things
no i think i think
avery had to go so we don't we don't
know from him
but that's another okay
well at least it wasn't like the meeting
yesterday where all the people who were
relevant weren't there
okay so you have to talk to rob but that
is my suggestion my suggestion would be
to fold system exception in with
terminated evaluation and have it be a
cause of terminated evaluation well it
already is a cause of terminated
evaluation because no i know but of the
of the terminated evaluation wrapper
right total evaluation no no no no my my
the terminated evaluation wrapper is
created by
the uh you know by catching a system
exception of type iteration limit or
recursion limit and then you know
stopping okay fine
stopping the exception and changing the
head okay we're fine so then then then
this is a malloc failed type type
version of terminated evaluation
okay well we can certainly uh i think
that's not stupid point of view right
whether it's correct i'm reserving
judgment until no i agree
with them
because there may be some other you know
weird state that's left over by this
that we need to be able to unwind out of
yeah
all right thanks a lot guys
see you later
you